COLIN FREDERICKS: We've talked some
about the meaning of the cards.
But now I want to show you how
they're used for fortune-telling.
I'm going to shuffle the deck.
And then I'm going to lay
them out in one of the most
common patterns, the Celtic cross.
Normally, we would be doing a
reading for a specific person.
In this case, I don't have
someone to do a reading for.
So I'm just going to talk
about what the cards would
mean in different positions.
The first card is intended
to represent the person who
is asking the question, the querent.
This card is laid in the
center, upright or reversed,
however it's drawn from the deck.
And then another card
is played across that.
This card represents the problems
that the person is facing.
In this case, our first card was the
Three of Swords, which you can tell
is somewhat a bleak card
to begin with, and then
has been crossed with the Tower.
The Tower, as we've mentioned before--
it's quite a difficult card.
You can see that it's a bit of
chaos, either upright or reversed.
To the left of these cards,
we place one that represents
the past of the person in question.
And to the right, we place a card
that represents their future.
Above, we place a card that represents
the conscious goals of our querent.
Below, we place one that represents
their subconscious goals.
You can see a lot of duality here--
the self and the conflict,
the before and the after,
the conscious and the subconscious.
After that, four cards are stacked from
bottom to top on the right-hand side.
The first one represents advice
that should be given to the querent.
The second one is about
external influences,
which could be positive or negative.
Card number 9, second-to-last,
represents the hopes and fears
of the querent.
This is one card where
it's especially important
to look at both the regular
meaning and the reversed meaning.
Finally, our last card, card
number 10, is about the outcome
that is likely to occur.
This outcome card can also be
read both reversed and upright.
You can think of it as if you
take the advice, this will happen.
If you don't take the
advice, that will happen.
This requires a lot of work between
the fortune teller and the querent.
You need to understand
the meaning of the cards.
But you also need to
understand where that person is
when they're asking the question.
You can't just do a
reading blank for someone.
You need to know a
little bit about them.
So that's one of the most important
things to know about all of this.
You can't automatically generate this.
Just because someone takes the
advice that was prescribed for them
doesn't mean that they are going
to be free with their money
or that they're going
to be covetous of it.
You need to understand where
that person is in their life
and what the appropriate advice
to give is based on that card.
You can't just read it straight
and hope that it works.
This is common across a lot
of fortune-telling systems,
including Ifa and the Yoruba tradition.
You really need a connection
with a human being.
So this is the Celtic cross.
It's not the only
spread that you'll see.
People will arrange cards in different
ways, especially with different decks.
But it is the most common.
And if you go to a fortune teller,
you might see them use this spread.